[Musique]
ce sont des agricultrices des
entrepreneurs des cuisiniers et aussi de
fins gourmets
[Musique]
ils ont entre 4 et 12 ans et c'est jovan
finissants de 6e qui tous fiers nous
fait visiter son école un peu spécial
en fait comme ici puis s'est mis tout ça
se fait peu importe là je le peux que sa
première année sixième année sa chaîne
de première année à chemin et je me
disais parce qu'on a des écoles de sport
de musique et soupe qu'on n'a pas
d'école agroalimentaire alors logé
semaine petit grain
le programme agricole l'agroalimentaire
s'invite à l'école a d'abord été pensé
par maryse côté directrice de l'école
primaire louis de france à trois
rivières c'est l'aboutissement d'un long
processus qui a débuté en 2005 en 2020
on se maintient on remplit le basilic
puis des belles flanc au début les
enfants l'eau avait de la difficulté à
mettre les mains dans la terre
aujourd'hui on va s'aimer de l'année
[Musique]
c'est un des des objectifs du programme
de revenir aux sources
puis les enfants répondent tellement
bien l'eau par leur émerveillement
devant tout ce qu'ils apprennent dès la
première année on s'aime et on ne se
gêne pas pour se mettre les mains dans
la terre
[Musique]
descoings ce pavillon le thé la clenche
sectionne en forme c'est vraiment bon il
ya eu un peu de graffitis ce que j'aime
pas trop des aliments jeu de petites
pense que on les trouve comme ça dans la
nature une serre côtoie un avion tout
nouveau pour accueillir jusqu'à 60
élèves non transformé on a voulu créer
un environnement convivial pour les
enfants pour qu'ils vous puisse être
plus souvent à l'extérieur autant
l'hiver comme l'été
alors les enfants peuvent être un peu
plus dans la zone de nature donc dans un
petit amphithéâtre pour pouvoir avoir
une bonne classe avec l'enseignant des
thèmes différents sont abordés de la
maternelle 4 ans à la 6e c'est le crime
en plus grande quantité
[Musique]
à quelques pas de l'école ou services de
garde une grande cuisine peut accueillir
les élèves afin de mettre en pratique
les notions acquises chez vous ils vont
savoir les apprentissages qui se font à
l'école mais aussi qui se partagent à la
maison avec les parents et les
grands-parents également c'est pour moi
les crêpes
ici il est d'abord de tournesol qui nous
apporte une sur deux côtés on parle de
l'origine de la production des métiers
associés on a plein de petites capsules
qui ont été faites pour justement
expliqué c'est quoi les métiers de
l'agriculteur de l'apiculteur et cetera
le boulanger donc l'enfant voit c'est
très jeune
tous les métiers reliés à l'agriculture
plutôt choisi un programme au secondaire
qui est en lien avec ce que tu as pris
six mois je me range confiance pour être
beau temps nous disait qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui était construit avec
des sons loin des branches de choses qui
ont été placés dans une façon si tu veux
coucher je trouve que c'est une vraiment
bonne et sebo cerveau fait vraiment bon
tout a été pensé pour que l'enfant soit
vraiment en immersion dans un monde de
plus naturel et on a des jardins
thématiques
alors on ne le jardin des pollinisateurs
le jardin des plantes médicinales le
jardin des plantes comestibles et le
jardin des parfums
c'est extraordinaire que ça soit à cour
d'école qui changent n ya pas beaucoup
de monde et pas beaucoup de temps quant
aux chiens les choses quand sur
[Musique]
l'apprentissage de l'agroalimentaire
s'intègre de plus en plus au programme
pédagogique régulier on a marché de jeux
éliminé
on a un groupe d'élèves qui s'occupe du
marché et le coût moyen chef chaque
balle en touche en provence a fait donc
deux ans à fenouillet les légumes ils
ont évidemment à les vendre donc ils
vont calculer la marge de profit les
coûts de revient est tous au camp mieux
vendu de contenus vélo gagne 2,81 mais à
quel coût les volants de jeu des
mathématiques que yo des sciences
j'aimerais ce qu'on sorte les concepts
qu'on a vu pendant toute l'année en lien
avec le compost parc les fruits les
légumes
évidemment ici rien n'est perdu un
concept d'école ou à la récré concéda le
smoothie des pierres de ton école
joindre c'est geoffrey rush et cherche
une vraiment belle école tout cela est
rendu possible grâce aux efforts
soutenus de maryse et de son équipe de
parents bénévoles et de bourse du
ministère de l'agriculture et
d'entreprises privées
c'est la fin pour hugh van es la fin
pour madame maryse mais pas pour le
projet agricole
se termine cette année et puis c'est le
cas on remplit de fierté là que je vais
terminer à l'école louis de france de
volley
pour les loger sans vraiment que le
projet était à des ailes et puis l'on
est à créer évidemment le tout ce qu'il
faut pour l'exporter ce projet lol dans
les autres écoles qui désirent
l'implanter un exemple d'école où l'on
sème en scène cet été je vais
[Musique]